carlos pena Vega prepares to perform in
Greece live on Fox January 31st we are
two weeks out how are you feeling how
are the rehearsals going I think the
nerves are starting to come in now the
26 year old actor tells et at the winner
TCA pressed or then he's ready to step
into an even bigger role as a father
revealing he and his wife Alexa are
trying to get pregnant when am I gonna
get a little mini Penna Vega from you oh
my gosh I would love to get a mini
Pennebaker out but it's a lot harder
than I thought
today's trying it's not as easy well
I'll just say when it happens it happens
this Dancing with the Stars couple will
hopefully pass down the dance gene to
their baby boy or girl however Carlos
sells ET Alexa hopes one of his talents
gives their mini meet I'm keeping my
fingers crossed because that would be
the cutest little baby ever and so
talented of a dancer believe me I'm
gonna teach you to sing dance do things
hopefully doesn't fart because I have
that talent because that's what it likes
it tells me that I can't teach the baby
yeah not that there is a baby or
anything I'm gonna go